Both of the functions we have here output real numbers for y, for any number of
x that we could plug in. So the domain of each is all real numbers. In other
words, negative infinity to infinity. The ranges of both of the functions are
the same as one another, as well. They are both 0 to infinity, not including
either of those endpoints. Now we can see this happening on either graph, but
why is it happening? Here is an instance where our equations can lend a hand.
No matter how small a number you plug in for x in our exponential growth
function, 2 to the x will never reach 0. The numbers will get closer and closer
to 0, but they'll never actually equal it. For the exponential decay equation,
if we look way out to the right side of the graph as x approaches infinity, y
will approach but never touch 0, since the same thing will be happening with
this equation.